hello welcome I've called this torque
modern web application bugs it turns out
that a lot of the stuff that we find to
be modern is actually quite old so um
we'll get back to that but some of the
stuff is modern in the sense that it's
retro it's come back I'm either really
stupid or quite brave because I'm gonna
do a lot of live demos or at least some
live demos and those things can fail and
I don't have any video back up because
it's demo or die so my apologies if some
of them don't work I'm Alan I work at a
company called Blanc in Oslo in Norway
I'm spent most of the days as a
developer but I also do security testing
and I've also started doing bug bounty
hunting and this is kind of the place
where I started to run into all these
kinds of newer types of bugs that we can
find
I also build open-source security tools
and I'm head of the OS Norway chapter
and Oslo and you have my Twitter handle
there as well so we had a new revision
of the OS top ten come out last year and
in this we had a couple of new entries
we have a 4 which is XML external
entities and a 8 which was insecure
deserialization and for many of us who's
been following the industry for some
time we were kind of waiting for this to
come because these have these are things
that people have been exploiting a lot
lately if we go into the bug bounty
space and read the reports from the
companies this is from this is from
bugcrowd
we see that it's kind of the old things
all over again
it's like cross-site scripting is
actually two places it's down at the
bottom as reflected and at the top as
stored and we have things like the
classic stuff really if we go to a
hacker 1 which is another bug bounty
platform the font is a little bit small
but it says cross-site scripting at the
top and there are some sequins action
and there's some stuff in here but if
we're going to look at the newer stuff
we might have to move outside of these
classic things but the first thing I'm
going to talk about is actually one of
the things that is on the OS top-10 the
new version
and it has to do with XML because XML is
fun so here's my first live demo I have
at the top here I have a URI and I have
some XML that I want to send to the
server and I can click this send button
and it will send the XML to the server
and print response in the in the lower
window so xxe this is actually a bug
that spin around since I think 2002 but
it's it's come back a lot lately because
people write new types of XML parsers
and they are vulnerable to this all over
again so the idea here is we can we can
declare a doctype at the top here and
this doctype we can define a system
entity and a system entity basically
means go read this stuff from the system
and then put this in the content entity
and then when we using this entity down
here we're actually going to get the
output from that file which is handy and
we can also do things like replace this
with a dot which would mean list the
files in the current folder oh there's
something called passwords txt and that
sounds useful let's look at that summer
that's a good password I'm sure no one
else has that but we can do more because
we could use something called XSLT like
we could transform an XML into an HTML
so in this case we can send in instead
of sending in an XML we're sending in
way out for to transform our current XML
into an HTML so it would come like a
table with some stuff in it's really
boring stuff but of course XSLT can have
stuff in it as well so we can start
querying system properties like this so
instead of showing the XML that was
boring we're now grabbing stuff out of
the system so we can see which version
of XSLT which provider etc down here but
again not that super useful what if we
could read files just like with the with
the xxe stuff well we can there's a
function
called document and XSLT which can bring
in another XML document into the
rendering so in this case I'm grabbing
the pom.xml and for those of you who are
who are not Java developers palm is like
a package config or package Jason it's
it declares which kind of which kind of
dependencies this system has so that
could be useful but we can do more we
can have xx C in the XSLT instead of in
the XML because XSLT is also an XML and
that works just as fine as the other one
and also we saw that we had XSLT version
2 it has a new nice function called
unpark text which means we can bring in
fights that aren't valid XML as well
like this stealing the file once again
or we can actually start querying around
the network instead of providing a file
name we could provide a URI and in this
case we find that there's some
elasticsearch server on this network and
this might be something we couldn't
access from the outside because it was
it wasn't accessible directly on his IP
it was kind of behind the current server
that we were looking at so this is kind
of scary
luckily for dotnet developers Microsoft
patched all their up our sirs back in
for dotnet for 5 - I think it was so
you'd actually have to enable this for
it to be vulnerable but it's really
important that you know this sometimes
we don't get the result back immediately
so we can do something called blind xxe
and in this case we're going to where
you can actually bring in we can bring
in an external DTD from a from our own
hacker server and this looks like this
and what we're going to do here is we're
gonna steal the contents of the file put
it in the data 3 entity here and then
we're gonna put that at the end of the
array a URL down here and we're gonna
when the when this is parsed it's
actually gonna grab the contents of this
file and send it off as a part of trying
to reach this URI so again we could
steal stuff without even getting the
response back immediately as we saw in
the previous examples
this is a report on actor one where
someone found a neck sexy these are
really useful you should go read this
stuff because you can learn a lot from
reading these things there's one
interesting thing with this one and it's
if we look at the severity here they say
it's medium but if you look at the
payout that was given to it to this Josh
Brody it was ten thousand dollars from
Twitter for finding this so maybe the
medium and the bounty is kind of out of
tune I don't know
so that was X exceed the next one is
also on the or top ten and it's called
insecure D serialization and this is
something that's been researched a lot
the last years talks on blackhat and
building of frameworks for doing this
and all kinds of stuff so so what is
this thing well serialization is
something we use for a lot of the a lot
of things like we use it for for REST
API is we use it for web services we use
it for all kinds of things where we have
to transfer some internal object on the
server into some format that we can ship
across the wire or send down to a
database so it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be a rest or web service
API it could also be things like a
shared cache it could be a file system
it could be all kinds of places where
we're sending things back and forth so
and and if this goes wrong we could
deserialize something into a dangerous
object and this could allow us to do
things like denial service we can
manipulate the state on the server we
could compromise the server or we could
even get remote code execution so I'm
gonna give you a very simple example
first so at the top here we have the
person object which is a completely
benign object it doesn't do anything
special it takes a it has a constructor
it takes a name and it assigns that to a
property nothing special about it and
then at the lower part of the screen we
have a gadget which is what we call
these dangerous elements that we can use
in in these realization attacks and in
this case it's a util class it's not
meant to be a part of the API and but if
we invoke the constructor of this with a
string that points to a file it would
actually start this file as a process
and normally this is hard to achieve
because we can't really target that
special file but for some reason it's
possible in some of these frameworks to
enable specifying the type so if we look
down here we see in this Jason you can
specify the type that this is supposed
to be deserialized to and same thing for
the XML down here and if we could do
this we could actually just send in
either this JSON or this XML and it
would actually start a new process but
this is a bit oversimplified because
usually we don't have things like this
lying around so we have to change stuff
and this is one example for a dotnet
this realization gadget which is using
something called object data provider in
the presentation framework and then it's
doing some stuff to bring in a say
process and then an ArrayList of
arguments which is in this case is the
calculator and then it invokes the
method called star on this but let's
let's do the demos on this as well so I
have here I have a this is a Java
derealization attack where we it's the
same API that we looked at earlier but
in this case in this this time we're
going to create a proxy for the contact
object so this is under going to detail
on how this works but if we if we try to
do something like this it's going to
create a process builder and it's going
to run ping with some stuff here but of
course we can't see what's going on and
it's it appears that it failed down here
so but let's do something more
interesting we're gonna create a small
little listener on our hacker servers
and we're gonna listen on a porch and
then we're gonna try here to create a
remote shell back to this server that
we're listening on here oh now I'm in on
this server and I'm logged in as root
quite dangerous I would say so these
these things are super scary this is an
example from Starbucks in India once
again from hacker one someone found a
code injection here in something called
a bus MQ
and this these things happen a lot and
and really go read these reports are
great the next thing we're gonna look at
is something called server site request
forgery you might have heard of
client-side request forgery CSRF which
used to be on the OS top-10 but was
recently removed and server side
requests are kind of similar except they
happen on the server so we can trick the
server into doing something it shouldn't
do so we could have something we could
have a setup like this we have a browser
which talks to a reverse proxy or some
other type of server-side application
which again talks to another server so
this could be like a micro service or
something like this and sometimes we're
able to influence how this second call
is made so I'll give you an example here
we have a request coming in from the
browser and it goes to example the toric
slash images slash 200 by 200 slash
product or JPEG and in the server
application we're going to replace the
first part of the URI before we actually
make the lookup to the backing system so
we're gonna take the original URI just
drop something of it and then we replace
it with images dot example.org and go
grab the file and and stream it back to
the end-user so we we strike out the
first part and then this is the NGI that
we actually look up but there's quite a
few problems with this first of all what
happens if we did this like images dot
evil com
well it's gonna remove the first part
and and it's gonna look up images dot
example.org dot evil.com which is our
server so that's useful maybe they use
some kind of authentication tokens that
we can steal also we could do something
like this and in this case it would be
images of the example at work and then
dummy so this would be a basic
authentication where images taught
example torgus the username and dummy is
the password and then we try to fetch
stuff from an internal server it could
also be something like this maybe we
have some functionality in this
application where it's supposed to be
able to import some data from an
external source and we could start
poking around the internal network
instead and grab some stuff from a
MongoDB or something like this or we
could even do something similar to the
ecstasy stuff we could start grabbing
files which is going to be
you useful but one of the things that
this is very often useful for is
grabbing stuff from cloud services so on
ec2 and other types of clouds providers
they have a special IP it's 169.254
169.254 this is the metadata host and it
can provide things like security
credentials so basically keys to login
to the server we could also use this of
course to grab stuff off of databases or
other services but recently it's been
used a lot for these cloud services so
what we're thinking now is okay so this
IP is dangerous let's block it it turns
out that that can be quite hard so a guy
called Nicaragua who's a French guy
doing a lot of esos RF research he found
that a lot of IP address parsers they
are very permissive so we have our
regular IP and then we have our regular
IP with overflow so it's just gonna
truncate it it's gonna do mod 256 and so
these are basically the same eyepiece
this is an America P this is a numeric
IP with overflow this is a hex IP this
is a hex IP without dots this is a hex
IP without dots but with overflow this
is an octal IP this is an octal IP with
overflow ah okay so this IP stuff is
kind of hard so we were not gonna allow
eyepiece we're gonna just allow host
names instead okay what I could of
course set up my DNS to point to the
same IP or to local host if I wanted to
there are actually services that do that
already so you could just do the IP dot
sip io and it will resolve to 127 0 0 1
we could base 36 encode that IP so it's
not that visible or we could even do
like a hope fake host name at the front
there's also www banknote dot and this
base 36 thing and then sip to dial which
again resolves 227 series or 1 also 0 0
0 0 that's usually like all the
interfaces of our system so we might be
able to reach stuff there as well and it
turns out that one
27 is also like you don't have to do
service everyone that's what we normally
do but you could do 127 4 times and that
would work as well and then ipv6 comes
along and we get all these other kinds
of weird stuff that pops in and this is
once again an example from hacker 1
someone found one of these and if we
look closely here we can see all the way
down here a very familiar IP 169 to 5-4
169.254
so the same IP so as I said this is one
of the things that people have been
using as a syrette for they can go grab
these these access keys and then look
they can basically SSH into the server
with these access keys the next one
we're going to look at is something
called template injection this is it's
kind of a part of the OS 1210 because
you could probably put it into a one
injection but it's also quite new and
it's also related to the way that we use
different types of frameworks so our
template could look something like this
so we have these curly braces they they
tell us that in this place we're gonna
insert some data and what a lot of these
frameworks will actually do is something
like this so they'll pull out the
strings and then they'll do an eval of
the stuff that's in between and to run
it basically and that as long as we are
the provider of that template that's
fine I mean we added the stuff in there
and we are the developers of this system
so that's fine so if we had a template
that looked something like this and we
had a title variable that contained
hello the end result would be h1 hello
the problem occurs when we try to
combine templates so we have one
template and we want to have like a
module system so we want to bring one
template into another template and we do
it the wrong way so in this case we
render the first template and then we
insert the rendered result into the
second template so if they both contain
normal strings there's no problem it's
hello and it's world and things render
properly but if the first bar the first
rendering contains a template that
template is going to run as part of the
evaluation of this
second template so in this case title is
2x2 and with the curly braces and so
it's gonna be rendered into a new
template which we insert into an
existing template and then we double
evaluate the first part which is the
dangerous thing so no no fun without a
demo right so here I have an application
and if I click here it just and I
specified my name up here in just as
hello Allen and we have my name down
here as well so in this case it renders
the HTML on the top and it shows the
source of the HTML at the bottom so we
could do 2 times 3
it says hello 6 because it double
evaluates this so we see that this comes
back from the server as a 6 but of
course math we could do that in
calculator so let's do something more
fun let's try to figure out what's
running here so self ok some error thing
going on but it also reveals something
here this is a twig template and twig
had some some bugs in it so let's bring
up our hacker server and first we're
gonna just test that we can run code and
in this case we ran the ID command which
gave us the the which user this
application is running s but we could do
something like this instead so now if
you saw I now have shell on this server
I'm logged in as www data down here so
I'm I've hacked into the server as well
just with a simple Europe so ok sorry
I'm just going to do like this
there we go but this was server-side
right we saw that a two times two or
three times three came back as six but
we can have template injection
client-side as well so this case we have
one templating framework running on the
on the server and we also have angular
so if we look down here we see it came
back as two times three but up here as
rendered is said six because angular
went in and so okay there's something
going on here there's an NG app and
there's a template so I'm gonna run this
template this is something that can
happen if you have if you're mixing a
server-side templating framework and a
client-side templating framework or of
course once again math is no fun so we
could do like alert one right no because
this is angular and the earlier versions
of angular they had a sandbox and the
sandbox tells us that you are not
allowed to execute functions like that
but and of course this angular version
also had a bypass of the sandbox which
was you create a string and you get the
constructor of the string which is the
string constructor and then you get this
constructor of the string constructor
which is the function constructor and
then you create a new function
containing alert one and then you invoke
that function and then we get the alert
so we have cross-site scripting and the
funny thing here is you can see that on
n runs two times as well and you can see
that it was encoded down here but it
worked anyway because that's just the
way it works so we have to take care of
these things like we're using templates
and we're mixing things up we have to
take care of this we get some new
control characters in the mix when we're
doing these double types of templating
so if we're gonna stop template
injection we need to make sure we don't
double evaluate these templates and
mixing server-side and client-side
templating is also a really bad idea and
this was actually in the documentation
for angular for a long time but at the
end they decided just to drop the entire
sandbox because people were doing people
find bypasses for these sound boxes all
the time don't mix server-side and
client-side templating
the next thing we're going to look at is
insecure course so of course for
cross-origin resource sharing is a way
for our system to tell a website running
on a different domain than ours that
it's allowed to read data from us that's
basically it so we can use this header
called access control allow origin but
sometimes people have a hard time
understanding what it does so I got some
help from Google Translate to translate
from HTTP to English so access control
allow origin example.com and access
control allow credential true so if the
user is logged in and visits example.com
please allow that site to access to user
data okay that's probably what we want
but then we see developers doing this
access control allow Origin access
control allow credentials true and
translated it means if the user is
logged in please
allow any site on the entire internet to
access to users data and given that they
can trick the user into visiting their
site luckily for us the browser's get
really angry if we try to do this say ok
this is an insecure policy you shouldn't
do that but our friends the funny
developers day sometimes figure out ways
around these policies because they maybe
they misunderstand what these things do
and some frame I've been I was writing
some code the other day and and one of
the frameworks I used to have the bug
I'm not going to show you as a feature
so the mistake number one is the echo so
we grabbed the original header that
comes in from the client and we just
echo it back as access control our
region so now we have access control
allow origin star it's just not explicit
anymore so just gonna echo whatever so
is any site on the Internet can now
steal the data at once again we just
circumvented the policy mistake number
two
insufficient validation so ok we grab
the origin header and we check does it
end with example com okay we're gonna
allow it which means we also allow not
example.com because there's also ends
with example.com next one null all right
what does this mean
access control allow or rich
no access control allow credentials true
let's ask Google Translate so if the
user is logged in please allow any site
the user visits to access the users data
as long as the sites knows how to use an
iframe with the sandbox attribute like
this because if we create an iframe with
the sandbox attribute and we use like
this data thing here we're going to get
a null origin and so that would actually
be sent what is origin No
as you can see at the bottom area so
that's also a completely unsafe
configuration so a guy called James
kettle who works for port Swiger and
imports wiggers to create off the very
famous hacking tool or pen testing tool
called Bert's wit he did a lot of
research into this and this is one of
the things that he find he found so
coarse msconfig you know figuration on
szymek TOCOM and it would allow things
like not samito com
so I did the exact same thing that I
just showed so that's interesting
next thing subdomain take over for those
of you who were at Karen Jack Jacobson's
talked earlier today the boring boring
security talk as it was called he
actually mentioned this but under the
name DNS squatting so a Swedish company
called detective fire they have one of
the most famous bug bounty hunters
around in France who sin and he wrote a
long blog post about this a while back
and this what this does it exploit
forgotten DNS aliases so a lot of the
cloud services that we can use they have
the B's thing where you can you can
specify your own name as a part of your
ID at posts it points to their servers
and that allows you to kind of specify a
part of the name that's yours and it for
other types of services in
infrastructure as a service services we
also can sometimes specify our name or
we get some kind of an ID up front and
detective I they discovered that there
are over hundred services that allow
these kinds of things
and so but let's let's do an example so
we are a company and we create an applet
that's running on Heroku I think
actually Heroku is changing this now but
let's let's consider that it works as it
used to right now so we create an
application at nbc.com and but we want
this to have a proper or proper domain
name not like your oh crap
we wanted to be our domain name so we we
go we want NDC dot example the point the
comment to point to this so we go into
the DNS and we set a cname like an alias
so we said it in this example come
you're gonna go and look up this
somewhere else
so we do not look up for this and we ask
the name server we're gonna get back
well you have to go ask this other thing
so as we can demonstrate this with
Harrison and boxes instead so we're
gonna look up and you see the attackable
of network for instance and we're gonna
ask DNS of hackable of network where can
I find this we're gonna get back
go see Heroku dana's for this so we go
to Heroku Deena's we ask it where we
want the IP of this thing and we get an
IP back and now we can go and visit to
the actual site that we wanted to so
that works perfectly and we're happy and
we've been using this application for a
while but then at some point we don't
need it so we we remove it we we go into
the Roku GUI and we just delete it now
we don't need it anymore then we forget
about this DNS entry and then our friend
the hacker comes along and creates a
heroic graph with the same name that we
used to have and the attacker now
controls our subdomain ah that's not
nice fishing with a proper domain name
that's probably pretty effective you
could use this to also steal or inject
domain wide cookies
you could add all kinds of of stuff that
would make the company look bad or you
could even create HTTPS certificates for
that domain or for that subdomain so
here we have an example of this this is
a guy called Matthias Carlson also a
Swede who found one of these at Shopify
and here's another funny
example this is the certificate
transparency Lord and what's interesting
here is if you see the name of the
certificate
Simon Gursky has hacked prod to do bird
calm yes he was able to grab one of
their subdomain and get a certificate
for it and because the CAS are they have
to publish all the certificates that
they they create so this is stays in
this large like this and yeah so they're
probably not too happy about that the
last thing that we're going to talk
about is something called web cache
poisoning
now web cache poisoning is something
that again it's it's james kettle of
ports where did some amazing research on
this what he was trying to do was to
exploit unexploited bugs sometimes there
are bugs in web apps where we can
trigger some stuff that's going to
happen but we can only trigger it for
ourselves one of those things is for
instance self XSS or self cross-site
scripting so I can send in a request
from my browser and I can get cross a
scripting but I can't send it to anybody
else because you would have to set like
this weird header or something and you
can't trick another browser in it for
another user to do that and you have to
control their system but what if we
could do something with the cache so the
gist of this is we have a server where
our application is running we have the
cash sitting up front the first client
comes in asks for some content
there's nothing in the cache for it so
at the cache the cache server will go to
our server we'll grab the content store
it in the cache and then return it so
now the next client comes along ask for
some content and gets a hit because the
content was already the area the the
second client asks for the same content
as the first user so there was a hit and
so there's no need to go
the backhand server anymore we have a
cache hit nice then the attacker comes
along the attackers does something
malicious and there's no no hit on the
cache in this case so the request goes
to the backend the back-end gets this
malicious data from the attacker does
something stupid with it and then the
the this thing is stored in the cache
and returned to the attacker but now
when the next client comes along there's
a hit and it's the attacker stuff so the
our unfortunate client that comes along
later is going to get the poisoned data
so the attacker is able to poison the
cache put some bad stuff in there and
that's not very nice so let's see how
this works so what I'm showing you here
is we have the headers I'm going to send
at the top here so I'm going to send it
to the URI you see at the top and these
are the header so I'm going to send so
send this on and the important thing to
look at here is this thing here so it
says I'm gonna load a script from web
dot hackable dot network okay
nothing bad going on but then the
attacker comes along and the attacker
sets another header because the
attackers figured out that this
application if it gets this header it's
gonna use it the wrong way and X
forwarded host is something we often use
in in reverse proxy to tell it what this
was the original host that came in and
you should treat it as such so the
attacker can now do this send in this
and in this case we see that it says
attacker come here instead because this
was used the wrong way the URI is a bit
different though there is something at
the end here so our our our friend over
here we'll still see web detectable
network so what we can do we have to
poison the exact same URL or at least we
have to figure out which parts of the
permian parameters are a part of the
cache key in this case we if we try to
poison it without anything or we can I
can actually show you this first we can
poison it with this like like this it's
a tracker let's call me
and I tried to change it to let's see
not attacker.com and I tried to send it
now I'm just hitting the cache so it
still says attacker calm it doesn't
change to not the attacker but if I
change this URL parameter because that's
the part of the cache key it's going to
change down here but I want to put
poison into root so now I'm going to try
this and we now have not attacker on the
root so our friend the friendly client
comes up comes back and it now says not
attacker.com without this user sending
this header but this is boring now I
want to hack you guys so please bring
out your phone or your laptop and try to
go to this URI there's nothing dangerous
there no worries
I promise what do you see on this URI
when you open
so it's dub-dub-dub hackable dot network
you see the NDC conference logo right so
it should look something out sorry ruin
it so it should look something like this
right that's what you see it's not going
to try to poison this page and this
might take a bit of time because there's
a cache this thing is pretty friendly
forests down here it says how long it
keeps the cache so it's a cache control
public max-age 60 seconds that's helpful
when we want to poison caches so now my
slide set is hammering this server
trying to poison the cache and hopefully
at some point after about a minute it's
gonna say success instead I will see
success now try refreshing the page in
your phone what do you see yeah too bad
I spoiled it already but you should now
see this person instead so I just
poisoned it I didn't do anything on the
server I wasn't logged into the server
anything I just poisoned the cache with
this
so there are some tricky headers in the
bold hair these are some of the headers
that James kettle found X host or
explore the host they basically do the
same thing they tell it which which
probably was the host but some systems
also support things like X original URL
or x3 right URL where you can actually
trick the cache into cashing things as a
different URL so you can send in on one
URL and make it cached as another URL
which is kind of strange and of course
very useful as an attacker
so what James kettle did was he scanned
like the entire internet and found a lot
of these things and a lot of the big
services were vulnerable to this but
hopefully most of them have now fixed
this stuff
what can complicate this attack is we
have to know which URL parameters are
used in the cache keys and this can be
kind of difficult to do by hand because
there can be a lot of URL parameters and
we don't know which ones of the ones are
important sometimes user agent is used
so you could poison the cache for a
given you a given type of a browser so
you could cache it you could poison it
only for Firefox or only for a chrome or
only for IE maybe if it was like an old
IE version you could poison it for only
that version and then you could instead
of changing a picture you could run an
exploit which could be useful so you
could target specific groups a james
kettle created a plugin for burps with
called parent minor which actually does
this for you it tries to figure out
which headers and parameters are
actually part of the cache key so that
can be quite useful to test with so how
do we stop web cache poisoning can be a
bit difficult we we should at least not
allow these headers to come in from the
outside because if we go back to this
drawing here there's no reason why this
X forwarded host header should be
allowed from the outside through the
cache and into the server itself it
should be stopped here this nor if we're
using this header
it's probably need to be used between
the cash and the back-end servers we
don't need the attacker sitting on the
outside to be allowed to specify so we
should probably block those or replace
what's coming from the outside with
something that we control we could also
add the headers to the cache key so
instead of someone being able to poison
it for everyone they can only poison it
for someone with the same host header
which basically would mean you're the
attacker is stuck back at the problem
where it's an exploitable because you
can't send this thing we could also use
the Barry header to specify our
sometimes you can you can have the
backend service specify which which
headers and things are supposed to be a
part of the cache key but other times
you have to specify it in the cache
itself of course you should sanitize and
encode all inputs so what we could do in
this case instead of just replacing the
host name we could probably also do a
cross-site scripting attack because we
could of course this was a cross-site
scripting attack to begin with because
what we did here is basically replace
where it was loading this thing from but
we could try something like this as well
just to see what happens just change
this because loaded it now oh I changed
the wrong thing sorry this one
I'm just gonna change just a 5 so now I
I kind of accepted this thing so it was
like yeah just a string inside somewhere
I could now break out of it and and I
could do cross side scripting this way
so this is normally how this self fixes
our stuff would work and we could audit
our pages with burps wit and this para
minor extension but of course burps wit
is a tool that is it it costs money it's
not a free tool there is a free edition
but you can also purchase it but it's
quite cheap and it's really really good
so I highly recommend that you try it if
you haven't
there are some resources if you want to
read more I'm gonna let this stay there
for a short while the top one is
disclosed h1 this is a Twitter account
which publishes all the reports from
hacker 1 which are made public so it's
really nice to just follow that one and
whenever someone one of the programs on
hacker 1 they publish a report with some
details in it they're gonna tweet it you
could also go to hacker 1 to D 2 under
activity and you could find it there
this the next two links are some tools
called why so serial these are the
serialization tools so you have Y so
serial and why so serial and these allow
you to do these DC realization attacks
on different systems we have some things
that I find useful like the XSLT for
practical attacks and the server-side
templating section once again by James
kettle which I used for creating the
template injection thing you have the
blog post from from detective I hostile
subdomain take over using Heroku github
and etc this nikola Gregoire has this
paper which actually slides I think from
from a presentation he did only on SSR F
you should actually look up the video
because he has some really great
examples in there of how he's used as a
ref to hack things then there's
exploiting course miss configuration for
bitcoins and bounties by James kettle
that I did at the apps you last year and
then
there's a blog post and a paper and a
presentation from James kettle on
practical web cache poisoning that you
can find on the porch sugar block and
that's it the demo app actually that I
used to run xxe and this realization is
on github so you can find it you can run
it as a docker container and in the
readme file you can find all the things
that I sent to it so you can try it out
yourself if you want to any questions
no questions a rest day or are you all
scared and want to go home alright then
I'm just gonna stop thank you